[Music]
we're here at the premiere of Netflix's
true in the rainbow kingdom the new
children's series executive produced by
Pharrell we're here on the red carpet
catching up with all the stars I have to
tell you we're loving you on Riverdale
our new favorite show what the
experience been like for you it's
amazing man up after what I just saw in
there she needs you
I love Cole I love KJ all the girls
everybody's really really good people
and so it makes it fun and I think Luke
and I are gonna wind up sharing an
apartment in Vancouver so it could be an
interesting 90s literally it's a hot
dads club it's you it's Mark Consuelos
it's Luke Perry is that the five on set
are you three like styling out having a
great time well we don't really work
together that much so Luke and I yeah
when we did last season you're on-screen
son Cole's has been linked to Lily
Reinhart they've been spending some time
together what do you think well I know
they spend time together because they're
at work all the time together but I'm
not surprised they have a great
chemistry they've been at our house with
a lot of the Riverdale people and they
always enjoy each other's company so I
wish them the best special connection it
seems like it it seems like it yeah I
mean you just hear them talking to each
other like they've been best friends for
20 years so that's a good sign
[Music]
you